[Music]
coming up next it's book notes with
kevin phillips author of the politics of
rich and poor wealth and the electorate
in the reagan aftermath he examines the
concentration of wealth in america and
its impact on the country's political
structure
[Music]
kevin phillips author of the new book
the politics of rich and poor
wealth in the american electorate and
the reagan aftermath what's the point of
your book
i think the point of the book is that
during the 1980s the people at the top
in the united states
really got a lot richer more so than any
other part of the country
policy had a lot to do with that the
favoritism of tax policy monetary policy
deregulation and as a result i think
what we're primed for in this country is
a frustrated middle class
who've wondered sort of what happened to
them but really didn't know who made out
are going to start understanding who
made out and that during the 1990s we're
going to see
pressure to change some of the
redistribution that occurred during the
1980s so i think
that is the the overall message and
interpretation of that book
on the back of your book uh you've got
two people who are quoted about what
they think of it
let me read the first one kevin phillips
is america's premier political analyst
his new book the politics of rich and
poor will revolutionize the way we think
about politics in the 90s just as his
1969 book the emerging republican
majority had such an impact on the
decade of the 70s former president
richard nixon why did you use that
well former president nixon was was kind
enough to give me a good quote and i
thought it was a
a quote that was very much to the point
i mean i think his sense is that what's
talked about in that book is something
that's going to be an important
political dynamic of the 1990s you cut
your teeth on richard nixon so to speak
when
well i started working for richard nixon
in
1968
in the 1968 campaign doing political
analysis and then went into the
administration but only for a pretty
short time and came out but
i've kept in touch with him particularly
during the reagan years and he's been
been kind enough to say nice things
about previous books part of this one
and we have lengthy discussions from
time to time
he says nice things about your book
and your book says the rich got richer
and the poor got poorer what does he
think then of the reagan administration
well i wouldn't want to try to speculate
what he thought of the reagan
administration because he passes up the
opportunity to be blunt in any
assessment when he's asked he has
however said in
in some interviews this spring
that while he didn't want to criticize
former president reagan he didn't agree
with his evaluation of government as is
purely part of the problem and not part
of the solution and that he nixon back
during the the late 1960s looking at the
failure of liberal programs still felt
that you had to try to do something for
people that you had to use government as
a as a vehicle and government as part of
the answer so i think he has
has had some
personal descending attitudes towards
things that were done by
ronald reagan
what do you think of ronald reagan
well i think ronald reagan was a hell of
a man to be able to become president of
the united states in 69 and uh stand
tall for what he believed in i think he
served a lot of useful purposes
in his first administration i think he
represented a number of directions the
country had to move in stronger foreign
policy bringing government under control
whipping inflation
unfortunately i think in the second
reagan administration and there were
elements of this in the first that he
went too far
and that what we wound up with after
eight years of ronald reagan
was a
foreign policy that started to be
devalued under
the whole iran contra scandal an economy
that was a mountain of debt
so i think he sort of outstayed his
utility but i think we needed
a lot of what we got in that first
reagan administration the sum total of
the eight years i think
has a lot of troubling legacies what do
you think of george bush
i think george bush is somebody who's a
supporting
player for the the reagan era
who is now stuck with administering it
doesn't have any real sense of it i
think george bush is what i think of as
a tennis and trust fund republican he
represents a different type of of
outlook he certainly would never have
done a lot of the things reagan did
that were a little bit dubious because
bush is so cautious
but i think it's going to be very
difficult for him to survive
four years of having
basically to administer the results of
somebody else's ideology i think we're
starting to see some stress on that
already the other quote in the back of
your book is from somebody on the other
side of the political spectrum governor
mario cuomo
phillips says convincingly what
democrats
have not been bold enough to say and
republicans won't admit
we have redistributed redistributed our
wealth from the poor and working middle
class to the rich
we have compromised our fiscal integrity
and risk our world position philip says
that the people will compel what the
politicians have failed to do i hope
he's right every american should read
this book
as a republican in the nixon
administration does that make you
nervous
no it doesn't make me nervous i think
that
what we tried to be back
20 years ago and i say we although i
wasn't in the administration long but my
concept of what sort of new majority
middle american republicanism was about
was a lot more attention to the average
guy than i think the average guy has
received in the during the 1980s and is
receiving now from george bush
and to the extent that the democrats
want to pick up
the the banner of trying to represent
the average guy and a lot of them
haven't during the 1980s i think that's
a very useful thing i don't think that
american politics works well when
neither party is representing
the ordinary american and i think that
that's been the case during the 1980s
and if mario cuomo can help the
democrats start representing
what the democrats have always called
the little guy again as opposed to a
bunch of theorists and other people that
just want to go along with the white
house because they're scared and they
don't have any ideas if cuomo can make
the democrats represent that then more
power to him he hasn't totally proven
that yet though can he be elected
president
i think mario cuomo can be elected
president if the economy turns down in
the last two years or this year of the
bush administration if the republicans
have a strong economy heading into 1992
if they can keep the balls in the air
that long then i think the answer is no
mario cuomo can't be elected but no
democrat would be elected in that
circumstance i don't know if i count
right but 22 years ago i think you wrote
this book
the emerging republican majority this
was published by arlington house
whatever happened to arlington house by
the way i don't really know i'm glad
they were there in 1968 but i couldn't
tell you their status today does this
book hold up
i think it has
my sense is that the emerging republican
majority
emerged i mean there are people that
think that i wrote predicting an
absolutely top to bottom republican
majority talking about the
alabama legislature and the new york
city council
what that book projected
was that the republicans would dominate
the presidency pretty much for a
generation or more they have by the time
george bush's term is up in january 1993
the republicans will have held the white
house for 20 of the previous 24 years
that's basically
what i was writing about the national
politics and i think it's happened
watergate i have to say had me feeling
that it wouldn't happen back in 1973 and
74 but it did in the end
this may not mean much but the book that
the emergency republican majority sold
for
7.95 back in 1968 69
and the book that you put out now which
is about half the size sells from 1995.
does that say anything
well actually the inflation has been
more than that prices have at least
tripled since
1967-68
sure we've had a lot of inflation
there's no doubt about it i think the
inflation rate has actually been worse
than what the official rates have said
people
who have to buy
movie tickets and children's sneakers
and lunch and fast food places and pay
for health insurance pay their local
taxes it's really gotten out of hand the
middle class has been nibbled and
nibbled and nibbled but we have had a
lot of inflation what's happened to your
own views
about politics and the republican party
since you wrote your first book in this
new one
well my sense is that if you go back and
you look at the history of the
republican party and i don't think i
sufficiently appreciated this back in
1967 or 68
that it's taken power in some of the
great cycles of american history it's
taken power for broad-based reasons in
1860 with lincoln in the civil war in
1896 when william mckinley fought back
the
william jennings bryan challenge and
then in 1968 when the country was really
in some ways on the verge of
disintegrating from
riots in the cities riots in the campus
a southern sectional movement led by
george wallace and the republican party
has played a kind of nationalizing role
it's kept things together during these
particular periods
but once it's been in
for
10 12 more years than that
what we see is that it tends to i think
get
get too close to
upper bracket economics a kind of
capitalist heyday and it
it it does too much for the people at
the top and it loses sight of the people
at the bottom and i think the 1980s have
had a lot of that
reviews are mixed
some people don't like your book at all
and one that i'm looking at is from the
wall street journal it's a fellow by the
name of david brock who is with the
heritage foundation and that was
published on thursday june 14th did you
have an overall view of mr brock the
heritage foundation and why he didn't
like your book well i have an overall i
don't know mr brock at all i've never
heard of him but i have an overall view
of the heritage foundation and the
editorial page of the wall street
journal and basically it's they deserve
each other i mean if there are any
people who've been involved in sort of
blueprinting
the whole laissez-faire
[Music]
cut the taxes hands-off view of the
american economy during the 1980s it
would be
groups like the heritage foundation and
the editorial page which i differentiate
from the rest of the wall street journal
which is superb
the editorial page is uh
all these yuppies and red suspenders who
miss not going to morgan stanley during
the heyday running around and thumping
so i think that these are the people
whose policies i guess the book would be
would be dead against
so i can't say that i'm particularly
surprised that they're critical i mean
from their standpoint i think they
should be now you right for the wall
street journal still as a contributing
as part of their group of editors well
i'm a
a member of i guess you could call the
political strategist or pundits panel
they run on the back page of the wall
street journal
but what you have to understand is the
the internal divisions within the wall
street journal the editorial page
and the the news operations are totally
separate and the people that
that write the reporters for the
newspaper are a totally different group
than the wall street journal editorial
page and they don't share the same views
let me just pick out a paragraph of
course
this very fact ensures mr phillips
enthusiastic notices from the culture
police
all the more since his republican
credentials are seen to bestow a certain
gravitas to analysis that unfailing jibe
unfailingly jibe with prevailing left
liberal prejudices i didn't read that
well but you can see where he's upset
well yeah the cultural police that's
that's an interesting phrase where do
you meet the cultural police i mean are
they at movies do you see them going
into a bookstore
i think i know what he means but i'm not
sure what he's talking about or what he
would regard as the
i suppose the people who dominate the
media it's interesting that george
gilder
supply side economic theorist
referred to his principal opponents
being the
uh the elite of the information society
so i suppose the elite of the
information society are cousins of the
cultural police i mean as someone who
graduated from what was a fairly
populist republicanism back
years and years ago
i have to look with some amusement at
all of this this is
sort of populist labels used by people
that wouldn't know a grass root from a
piece of asphalt who who hole up in a
lot of these sort of rarefied think
tanks and
uh
and media operations themselves here in
washington
it's it's ironic when i wrote the
emerging republican majority all those
years ago what the democrats represented
were people who had taken over all these
washington institutions and who had just
become totally remote from the average
american and they they really had never
met a payroll they'd been on the on the
government
slots and think tanks that's what
conservatism is becoming we're producing
uh foundations and think tanks and
editorial rooms full of all these people
that have sit around and sucked
ideological thumbs for the last 10 years
so
it's an interesting development but i
think it's a sign of conservatism's
weakness
he uh he strings together a bunch of the
phrases you use and let me read that he
says indeed all this book really
demonstrates is how much the author's
high tone sensibilities
were deeply miffed by darwinism and
vibratory boone pickens and ivan boski
stretched limos and 300
cowboy boots champagne and raspberries
hustling middle class reagan aids and
right wing economists these are all in
quote marks rodeo drive sutton place and
the florida gulf coast
well those are all in there if you take
these nouns
they're in the book
they're not paired the way that they're
paired there they don't appear in the
same places they might be separated by
46 pages or 9 paragraphs i mean it's
that sort of thing
that i think i find sort of amusing
that's the sort of stuff the liberals
did
20 25 years ago when they were on the
skids those are skid marks
one last thing here from this this
particular review such images pepper
entire chapters filled with nothing but
lists
lists of billionaires and
centimillionaires and deca millionaires
lists of wall street 100 and the largest
golden parachute list of international
bank on and on he talks about lists uh i
remember reading in the emerging public
numbers
143 charts and you've done almost the
same thing in your new book why all the
charts
well i think the charts are critical to
proving the point there was one fellow
that
reviewed the politics of rich and poor
and he said that
where mario cuomo spoke poetry
what i did is i had
some of the style of an accountant and
he's referring to the number of charts
now of course the conservatives love the
charts that were in the emerging
republican majority and apparently they
don't particularly like these charts and
i can understand why
if you're going to prove the point it
doesn't do any good to simply say
something
what makes sense is to go in there and
lay it out to put down the numbers to
just put down the numbers from a lot of
different directions there's a chart in
there that shows how during the the
1980s
the the forbes 400 richest families
roughly tripled their net worth their
others on who made the most money in
wall street how much the top partners in
the the most prosperous law firms made
there are lots and lots of charts and
the point is that by the time you get
through the charts you've got a picture
and in this particular case
those pictures i think are something you
can't possibly do with words
so there's a reason for them
how rich are the rich
the rich are incredibly rich
see that's what's happened during the
1980s when i started writing this i
really didn't have as full of sense at
all i knew that there was a major change
that had come
but i really didn't have any sense of
how incredibly large it was
i mean there are if you take the the
number of billionaires in the united
states
between the early 80s and 1989 the
number of billionaires went from
something like seven or eight
up to 53 or 52. the number of
millionaires in the united states
climbed from about five or six hundred
thousand in 1980 up to 1.5 million by
the end of the decade the money made was
absolutely enormous and this is during
the same time
when the
uh median household income and the
median family income and things like
that
adjusted for inflation stayed pretty
much the same i mean they went up but
they only went up by a little bit so
what you had was an incredible situation
where the people at the top were getting
the big gains in the economy and that's
why things like architectural digest had
a surging circulation that's why they
had to put area codes on the atlantic
and pacific ocean so that people could
could dial their yachts
that's what happened to the united
states during the 1980s
why are we so fascinated i say we
meaning the american people through the
tabloids and the
magazines and newspapers with people
like donald trump ivan bowsky
uh you you know you know those kind of
people what is it about those kind of
people that we're interested in well i
think there are certain periods of
history where you can identify
first see change towards a more
conservative politics and economics and
then sort of at the same time
as that starts to catch hold and as the
economy starts humming and the markets
start booming and entrepreneurialism
starts surging
what you get is a fascination among
people with the people who are part of
this trend with the people who are the
entrepreneurs and the fat cats and we
saw this during the 1980s you saw that
the decade began
with shows becoming right at the top of
the tv list like dynasty dallas and
falcon crest that was sort of a
pre-trump mentality in itself that was
preparing people to watch the donald
trumps and people like them
and we had a fascination with that
during the 1980s i think that's curdling
now but there's just no doubt about it
it was a mainstay people admired glitz
they almost admired greed not quite but
they were fascinated by it one of the
things that you can see in your first
book the emerging republican majority
and this book the new one the politics
of rich and poor is the constant
referrals to cycles
where did you first get this notion that
cycles were worth watching well there's
a
sense among at least a considerable
minority of political scientists and
historians in the united states that our
politics in contrast to those of most
other countries have had a very strong
cyclical pattern
and they really have if you go back at
least i think so because you can see
that
uh in history in the year 1800 1828 1860
1896 and 1932 and then again in 1968
we had the beginnings of periods during
which one party really dominated
american presidential politics they
might lose once or twice in in 20 or 30
years but essentially they dominated and
when they won one of these watershed
elections a lot of things changed
and
as i read as a kid in school i i guess i
became pretty convinced of that and
during the 1960s i thought it was
happening again and when i was at law
school and after i got out of law school
i was busy pulling together information
and then after the 1966 elections i'd
gone down to washington i was convinced
it was happening again and i started on
the book that
became the emerging republican majority
and i think that it will be deemed to
have happened again on the national
level now we're kind of unique as a
country to be able to to go through
these things and i think it's because
the united states
first of all has regularly scheduled
elections in contrast to a
parliamentary regime when you never know
when they're going to come
so politicians can kind of build things
around elections and they've done that
in the united states the second thing is
that we've had these cycles i think in
part because they're regional and we've
filled in the country and as different
parts of the country have been settled
you've created different relationships
between the the prosperous part which is
usually the furthest part east and the
parts that are being settled
and then regionalism has played a role
so for all of these reasons i think that
cycles
are debatable in the united states but
have a
a more legitimate framework than in
almost any other country and i certainly
would emphasize them based on your cycle
theory what's next
what's next i would think would be a
center
to progressive something or other
reformist cycle beginning in the 1990s
back in 1968
where we began what has been 20 out of
24 years with the republicans and it may
well continue in 1992.
i was a little dubious that that it
would happen in the old way and it
didn't happen in the old way because it
didn't happen below the presidential
level nearly as much we still have much
more democratic strength
on the local levels and even in congress
now that the democrats have got the
senate back
so i think what we'll see in the 1990s
when we start a new cycle as it were
will be something that's even more
superficial and less fully rooted
and that the media make it less and less
possible to have the old deep-rooted
cycle where things change from the top
down to the bottom but i think what
we'll see is that the progressive
reformist populist i don't know quite
what to call it i don't think it'll want
to call itself liberal which is one word
i i don't think they want to use
we'll we'll get back in and that we'll
see more demand for government more
concern for the people who've been left
out
uh
more concern for for building things
again in the united states as opposed to
finance
taxes will go up there'll be more
regulation
hopefully there'll be some good things
too well you write about the cycles you
go back and show that the taxes were
real high uh back in the 20s and
and you'd do better at this than i can
and real low and this thing just keeps
going up and down so if we're at 28
right now you suggest that's going to go
back up to how high eventually well
that's an interesting question the uh
the first income tax in the united
states was put on during the civil war
and it was then taken off in the 1870s
as the whole populist crusade got
underway congress passed a law setting
up an income tax again in 1894 but the
supreme court threw it out so we really
got our first full-fledged income tax
beginning right before world war one and
it got up to a rate in the 70s during
the 1920s it came down from 73 to 25
which is kind of like what happened in
the 1980s when it came down to 70
percent to 28
but in the meantime back during the new
deal under franklin d roosevelt the top
rate got up to 91
so i think what we're going to see is
that rate goes back up again but i
wouldn't think it's going to go up
over 45 or 50. and the reason i don't
think that'll be the case is that
we're probably going to have to have
some consumption taxes
whether it's a much much
increased gasoline tax or some form of a
value-added tax or national sales tax
something like that and if we do i think
it'll it'll enable the top rate to be
kept at a level that's somewhere between
38 and 50 percent so i don't see much
likelihood of it going back up to 70 or
90 or anything like that
but i do think we will not see the 28
percent rate very much longer
who in history and and both recent
history and and american history or
world history do you admire the most and
politicians mostly well it's hard to say
because i guess i've been been too
involved in politics during a period
where disillusionment and politics sort
of went together whether it was uh
vietnam or watergate or carter or reagan
iran contra
now read my lips and flag desecration
i'm not too impressed uh
it's a very hard question for me to
answer i'm not sure i'm a good one to
even try you have a favorite president
in the 20th century
well of course i worked for nixon
there are lots of ways i think nixon
could
have been the dominant
president of the post-world war ii era
he muffed some of it and other people
helped take away from what he did do so
i don't think we can put him up for that
role
i think he was probably in many ways of
the brightest
but i know i i'm not in the game of
singling out who my
my great heroes or people i admire are
if you're so much in the business of
cycles in history
it gets pretty difficult because you
tend to evaluate them in ways that don't
deal with them as people
as historical forces as people who rode
waves as
creators of
of movements and that's really not the
yardstick for evaluating people one who
has to be identified in the 20th century
of course is franklin v roosevelt
there's no way around that more than
probably anybody else
the cyclical evaluation gives you
an awful lot of the ones that history
gives you that's an interesting overlap
i mean thomas jefferson andrew jackson
abraham lincoln
fdr maybe in a sense washington and
those are the cyclical people it sort of
suggests that when you're you're on top
of one of the cycles and you represent
the beginning of something
that wins and has a great historical
effect it sort of builds a presence for
you historically i think that has been
the record i'd certainly put all of the
people whose names i just mentioned
right at the top of any list of american
presidents you ever find yourself when
you read
either politicians or columnist quoting
history saying there they go again
there's another historical figure they
just keep trotting out whenever it
serves their purpose and in fact they
really weren't that great
or maybe a better way to ask it who's
the most overrated person in history
that you keep reading about
well if i were to go through that
in a sense one i'd pick would be woodrow
wilson
because i think woodrow wilson was naive
and woodrow wilson was taken to the
cleaners on the international stage he
gets an enormous amount of credit for
being a
a man of peace and global
uh foresight as it were
but yet with what he was involved in he
wasn't particularly successful
so there would be one uh
what about world his i want to ask you
about winston churchill and i know this
isn't fair to you because you haven't
heard the other interviews but for some
reason we've started talking about
winston churchill here and uh
from both sides christopher hitchens
says he was not nearly what americans
think he was
and uh cap weinberger writes in his book
that he was everything to him and he'll
be seen on book notes in a couple of
weeks
where does winston churchill fit in
your in your mind as a world figure well
my sense is that while winston churchill
had a number of the the weaknesses of
of of any politician and of his class
which was seen pretty vividly in 1945-46
when he had some difficulties with
readjusting britain to
its different circumstances after the
war but by any serious historical
yardstick he was a very very strong and
dominant and major historical figure
i mean beginning with his emergence on
the scene during even the uh
the boer war when he was captured in
south africa and he escaped and he
became a front-page figure in the uk
after that and
succeeded in winning a uh
a parliamentary seat out of oldham i
guess it would have been maybe 1901 1903
and when did he leave the the prime
ministership
50 years later
i mean this is a man that whatever
anybody might say to derogate some of
his particular circumstances or uh or
issue positions he marched across
50 years of british history like the
band of the grenadier guards and i don't
see how you can take that away from it
you mentioned the cycles and how
difficult it is to look at individuals
do individuals matter in politics
anymore
well i think they do i mean i have the
sense in the united states right now
that we have a set of
failures on the part of the republicans
and democrats and potential historical
convergences of great issues ready to be
laid out
of understanding by the american public
waiting to be recognized by politicians
who are less than the people they serve
and i think what we need is somebody who
can rise to that and somebody who can
can stand up and lay these things out
and who's good enough to do it so i
think individuals matter enormously
right now and i think we're paying the
price for the fact that
i wouldn't like to say we have third
rate individuals but i think
historically it's very fair to say
they're almost all second rate and what
we need is somebody who's not
you mentioned also that and i won't put
this in the context but you can about
the media and how it's difficult today
because the media is doing what to
i
mean
you went on to and indicate the media
was messing up the normal cycle
well i wouldn't say messing up but i
think what you had
the evolution of the cyclical pattern as
i think we've had it really began in the
united states because the united states
itself began pretty much in the period
of the industrial revolution
in the period where you had the
the move away from what had been an
aristocratic politics into a democratic
politics where elections became more and
more important and more and more people
participated and electorates were
mobilized and parties came to the fore
as opposed to factions
and as a result the earlier cycles in
this whole pattern from the 1800s early
1800s up through franklin d roosevelt
the new deal what you saw when politics
realigned it was pretty much a top to
bottom phenomenon because the the role
of the party was strong enough that it
became a major force i think in the
cycle we've had since 1968 one of the
reasons why you couldn't have a more
substantial realignment is first that
the the media were preempting in many
ways the role of the party as an
information distributor uh government
bureaucracies were taking over the old
role of the
party providing turkeys at thanksgiving
or helping people who are unemployed and
then last but not least the whole role
of the media being so prominent in
shaping people's views
every night every day they have the the
ability to speed up the process
that the the whole process of evolving
issues and
changing attitudes could be condensed
and exacerbated and and
pulled away from the actual old
structures and becoming much more
free-floating and i think that's what
we've seen i i don't imagine that we can
go back
to a 32 or 36-year cycle in american
politics as a matter of fact the one
we're in
may be the last that even approximates
that and what we get beginning in the
1990s may be a lot less rooted and a lot
more free-floating when you wrote the
emerging republican majority in 1968
there were only roughly
four television channels in most
towns
president could say i want time and get
it on
you know in prime time now the average
is 30 some
uh it'll just keep growing more and more
and you've got
70 percent of the american homes have
vcrs
60 of them have cable television is that
going to make it more difficult for a
politician in the future to get the
attention of the american people to
govern
i think it may make it more difficult
for a national leader to harness public
opinion either as a candidate
or as a president when he's in office it
should promote a balkanization of the
electorate and of power elites
on the other hand it certainly promotes
the ability of people to take off to
launch themselves as representatives of
either segments of the communications
world or of the people that watch a
particular medium or or of different
interest groups so i think it
probably increases the ability of
politicians to function in one way and
then decreases their ability to provide
another function we'll have to see how
it balances out because of this change
is there a different kind of person
that's going to be elected in the future
after george bush
well if you go back it's always it's
been tempting for people at different
points of history to say we're going to
see different types of politicians and
the funny thing is looking back
historically you don't really think that
because people and their personalities
and their desires and their weaknesses
tend to be the same
but it is true that there are certain
junctures in history where
the way politics behaves and some of the
weaknesses of it are very much
influenced by the media whether it's the
rise of hitler using radio or whether
it's the uh
actually very substantial modernization
of politics in the second
quarter of the 19th century because of
all the changes in communications from
the telegraph to the railroads so it
always does make a difference i don't
see that it changes the type of people
historically but we may well see within
the time frame of a decade or looking
back back at a quarter of a century the
ability to say well certain types of
people rose who never would have risen
before and you can say ronald reagan was
a media president he never could have
come prior to the
the age of the media i'm not so sure
because people have
have risen in politics who were
pamphleteers
200 years ago or for that matter 2000
years ago it's just a question of the
medium of the era i want to show the
audience the book it's politics of rich
and poor by kevin phillips it's in your
book stores and it's about i didn't
check it what 250 pages long yeah
roughly
a lot of a lot of charts
earlier i read a wall street journal
review in which the gentleman suggested
that you were going to be the darling of
uh the culture police and also uh of the
liberal media uh here is a very positive
review that was out this week in time
magazine along with a
looks like a fresh picture of you in
this uh does it worry you that he
predicted that the liberal media would
like it and
then here is a time magazine saying they
do like it and is this a liberal
publication
well it's an interesting question
whether it's a liberal publication i'm
certainly pleased that they like it i
mean as politicians have said
it's always better when people are for
you than when they're against you it
helps
and as someone who
was attacked by all the liberals
20 odd years ago and i got my my cheer
from the conservatives at that point
i'm not so sure you don't do better with
the media when you're getting more
from the liberals but
uh
i would suspect everything being equal
that the the greater preference for the
message in there is is on the part of
quote-unquote liberals but i also think
that it'd be a mistake to figure that
that's the basic source of
the the rise or fall of the message of
this book is going to come from middle
america
and middle america may not be as
conservative as it was three or four
years ago but it's not liberal
and the ultimate
i guess decision on on a book
or on ideas
in this system of ours
usually pretty much come from how
the average american reacts to it
i don't think it would do me a lot of
good if the average fella thought that
this book was a lot of hot air and the
new republic thought it was terrific i
mean frankly i'd rather have the average
guy and not the new republic
uh this is again a small point and i
tried to see some connection the book's
called the politics of the rich and poor
and you had a
chapter or at least a takeout in
this last sunday's new york times
magazine and they titled it something i
couldn't find in your book reagan's
america a capital offense what was this
article and where'd they get this title
well as the people that handle the new
york times
magazine processes will say
the the author gets
to have a fair say in any modification
made in text in other words when you
excerpt the book you take it in chunks
and you've got to blend paragraphs and
uh we have an epilogue in there that
wasn't from the book but i don't have
control over headlines or squibs so in
other words they're free to come up with
a different title
and reagan's america a capital offense
that's intended i think by the people
who wrote it which which wasn't me
to be a play on capital in the sense of
capital and the financial
and i don't really have much problem
with that because i think there was a
lot of financial mismanagement
in the sense do i think that the reagan
administration
was a capital offense
in the sense of a an offensive large
magnitude
second administration i have a lot of
problems with but i voted for ronald
reagan twice so if i'd been asked about
that title which i was not i would have
preferred something else
you are often labeled by people in the
media a lot of different ways what is
the label that you would most
like to have people put on you at this
stage in your life
well i'm not sure
there was some question for example on
the part of the people at the times how
i should be referred to conservative or
republican or both
and what they did is they ran a
a check on whether it was they just used
the new york times or they used nexus
so they they wanted to get a sense of
how i'd been referred to in the media
for the last 10 years and there were
there were hundreds of things that they
could take and
the predominant reference was
conservative and was republican i don't
have a problem with that
it's probably a problem for some of the
people who represent the current flavor
of both republicanism and and
conservatism but i guess i would say at
this point is probably fairer to call me
author and commentator or political
analyst or something and
maybe not to stress the the ideology or
the party that much but i don't have a
problem if somebody puts it in the
reason i ask that is that so many times
people are labeled in this business that
you're in
and a lot of people have find fault with
that and if somebody calls you a
republican political analyst does that
make you mad
uh the only problem i have with that is
if it's interpreted to mean that i
analyze things for the republican party
which i certainly don't do
but i'm a registered republican on the
books of whatever precinct it is in
montgomery county maryland so
technically speaking it's correct to say
i'm a republican
political analyst i just have no
connection whatever with the republican
party
this seems like an obvious question but
why do you write books
well sometimes i like it and sometimes i
don't i'm just in the process
of obviously having finished this and
starting at the stage of talking about
it and publicizing it and so forth and
it was a uh
a tiring effort as they are as you
more tiring as you get older i think
so i'm always tired of it after i finish
but i come back to doing it because as
richard nixon said in his most recent
book there's nothing that can substitute
for a book in clarifying and sorting out
your own ideas and putting them down and
then moving on to something else
and
he said in that book that each time he's
done one he said it would be his last
and i can remember actually him telling
me this is going to be his last this
one's going to be his last and it wasn't
and i'm sure this isn't my last i mean
if you write and if you you think and
you do this stuff there's something
fulfilling about it
how many books have you read
depending on the count you use i guess
in terms of book books this would be
number five
and what else are you doing besides
writing books
well i do a lot of different things i
i have two newsletters which i edit and
publish one is called the american
political report which has been around
for almost 20 years now which is
on politics and political economics and
elections and the second which is now 11
years old is called the business and
public affairs fortnightly which is on
business government relations corporate
external relations sort of uh
business and everything that affects it
from the outside
and i'm a commentator for a number of
different media and i've been a
consultant i go around and give a lot of
speeches and talks for one of the big
investment firms so i stay very busy the
other media national public radio you
still do that roundtable political
analysis you still do work for cbs cbs
that's right
i'm a
a commentator for cbs spectrum which is
their network radio and at the 84 and 88
democratic and republican conventions i
was a commentator for cbs television why
did you give up writing a column
i really got sick of the column it's
called feeding the monster
and the monster had to appear three
times a week
and i had
was willing to entertain the possibility
of once a week but three times a week
was a horrible experience and you find
yourself you'll produce one out of four
or five that you think is really good
and out of the other four or five two or
three will be okay but but nothing much
and there's always going to be one
that's a real turkey that you whip out
in 36 minutes when you were late for
lunch now there are people that are
perhaps more into
commentating than i am the whole notion
of going and interviewing these
politicians that i regard as you know
one notch above a melted hershey bar
uh that didn't appeal to me reporters
like to do that i
basically am interested in things that
don't involve actually
sitting and asking these guys so they
tell you something you know isn't true
and you go right about it anyway
so i wanted to get out of that and i
wanted to get to something whereby i
would write only uh
in terms of a column type thing that i
would write only 20 30 times a year and
then i'd get to write something was
large enough to be a think piece and i
do that now i do about 12 to 15 a year
for the los angeles times big ones that
are like 12 to 1500 words and then
usually anywhere from two or three to
five or six or eight others works out
very nicely i haven't had a moment's
twinge about not being a columnist
and when i've been asked that i want to
go back into it i've said no
where'd you grow up
new york city
where'd you go to school
uh
i went to the bronx high school of
science to colgate university the
university of edinburgh and the harvard
law school what'd your mother and father
do
well my mother was a housewife like i
guess most of our mothers were back then
in the 40s and 50s and my father started
as a new york state government civil
servant moved up to become
a commissioner and i suppose a little
bit of a politician but he never thought
of himself as that why did you get
interested in coming to washington
well the first thing i wanted to be back
in the middle of the 50s
was actually to go to west point and i'd
worked for my congressman as a
as a teenage campaigner and i guess i
could have had the appointment
but it began to become clear to me that
there was a long time between going to
west point and being a general and i
didn't think i'd make that good a
participant in the intervening stages so
i after the 1956 campaign when i started
to enjoy politics i forgot about that
and
i guess i'd had it in mind in one way or
another to come to washington
by the late 50s which is what i did
that's why i went to law school not to
practice law which i never have but to
play the groundwork for politics when
you came here who did you work for and
how long did you spend there
well i i got out of harvard law school
in june of 1964
and was asked i guess maybe about six
weeks later
to be the administrative assistant to
the
republican congressman from my district
whose name was congressman paul fino
and i worked for him in new york city
and then came down
to washington i guess it would have been
december of 64 january of 65 right in
time for the whole great society of
lyndon johnson
and i was working for fino uh
and enjoying being in washington and
being on capitol hill
and then after the 1966 elections i got
the idea that the whole republican era
that i had been sort of
reading about thinking about mapping as
a kid drawing maps of voting patterns i
thought that was going to come to pass
so i started writing the emerging
republican majority not under that title
i didn't know what the title would be
probably in november or december of 1966
and then i moved in 1968 i took the book
and i got a job doing the uh the sort of
political
district by district
voting history poll analysis for the
nixon campaign and that's how i
went into the republican campaign and
administration and matt nixon has there
ever been a time in the last 20 years or
a little longer than that where you've
been excited about what's been happening
in government here in washington
not very often
that's the whole problem i mean if you
go back and you take my political
generation at the ripe old age of just
49 i've been in politics for a long time
in the sense of in it or observing it
and i came down here in let's say
december of 1964
after what had been a bad period with
the kennedy assassination heading into
the whole vietnam era with with more
assassinations
than when we were of course happy after
the 68 election
but
that happiness didn't last you could see
it was an embattled administration
demonstrations everywhere the mall was
an armed camp the country was divided
then watergate came
you know then we had carter and that was
i think republicans in a small way
enjoyed the disillusionment of the
democrats who were just as embarrassed
then as
republicans had been during watergate
and democrats had been during johnson
i think it's been a disillusioning
quarter of a century i don't think it's
been a quarter of a century in which you
say my god weren't these
marvelous men in marvelous times
exciting in a sense yes but
not the period during which america put
its best people or its best foot forward
let me read you a little bit from your
book it's in the forward
that washington should seem irrelevant
to the average american dash a sinkhole
to be forgotten when the fish are biting
or a good movie is on television dash
means that republicans can keep the
white house until disillusionment can no
longer be avoided
most americans think this place is a
sinkhole i think they do and i also
think they think their state capitals
are buying large sinkholes
i mean i suspect that if you took a poll
in california on sacramento it wouldn't
get rave notices if you took a poll in
florida on tallahassee it wouldn't if
you took a poll in pennsylvania and
harrisburg and so on
and it's clear that americans don't
think washington does very much
it's a cynical
set of situations by which i think the
republicans the more americans believe
that government can't do anything the
less they will demand out of washington
the less they demand out of washington
the more it squares with republican
ideology of not doing very much now as
somebody who's republican antecedents go
back to a different portion of this
whole republican period i don't agree
with that i think the republicans uh
that this whole business with
flag desecration issues and
pornography much as i think that that
exhibition that jesse helms has
protested about in the nea situation
doesn't deserve federal funding it's
clear to me that the these issues that
are being trumped up or at least uh my
feeling that these issues that are being
trumped up now are evasions of the
larger national challenges and
i think that the washington has got more
of a role
ideally than washington is playing
washington has got to be the rallying
point for putting this country back in a
more effective set of policies and
outlooks
and whether you're republican or
democrat i think you've got to take some
of that view and i think it's a great
weakness of the present administration
that they don't want to develop that
that they alternate between pushing it
back to the states and saying well we
don't have any money to do it here where
there's a will there's a way i don't
think they have the will
in the world of politics and elections
where do you put money as
uh in the important importance level in
the economy
is it everything
you mean money in the sense of its role
in politics or money is an issue for the
average american or both well i guess
can there be a charismatic politician uh
who can win with straight charisma no
matter what the economy is or is it all
controlled in your cycle theory by the
economy
well my cycle theory involves a lot of
things that aren't uh aren't economic
when nixon won in 1968 i would say that
culture and patriotic issues were much
more than the economy which wasn't in
bad shape in 1968 partly because of the
war
i think economics is is often a dominant
force but by no means always
uh as much or more of american political
history has been a function of culture
and patriotism as of economics
and they weave together and sometimes
they go together and sometimes they
contradict each other in the early
stages back in the nixon years and
probably even into the early reagan
years democrats would lead the
republicans in terms of being trusted to
help the middle class or keep the
economy going but the republicans were
deemed to be much better on keeping
america strong or
preserving this or that value or
fighting crime or things like that so
it's a mix but i would say the the
really troublesome angle at this point
is that politics in the united states
now has become a matter of money in
terms of its technical aspects of
winning elections of being able to keep
yourself in power it's so much a
question of money that people who ought
to be having ideas are spending their
time uh raising money
people who should be going to a
committee hearings are going to
fundraisers people who should be
listening to their constituents are
listening to their contributors and the
net result is a politics that reflects
all that it doesn't reflect ideas it
doesn't reflect the
values of the grassroots they talk about
values but
why are fewer and fewer people bothering
to vote because their values are
represented no because their values
aren't represented
the last time it was down as low as it
is now is what 1924 or something like
that
yeah i would say that probably
it was right after women had gotten the
vote and women were sort of slow to move
into the same level of participation as
men were and it would have been in 1924
or right in there well then with no
extenuating circumstances is this the
lowest percentage of voters ever
no because you go back
into the 20s but if you go back before
the 20s
it probably is because
say in 19 in 1824 1820 or 1828 you were
just starting to have the
enfranchisement of ordinary people
uh right after the revolution you might
not have more than 10 12 15 percent of
the
the adult males allowed to vote in a
place like connecticut or new jersey
simply because they didn't meet the
property qualification
it's only by the 1830s that you're
getting past any of that and by the time
you did get into the 1830s and 1840s the
turnout was a lot higher than it is now
so in terms of the modern united states
where everybody can vote this is about
as low as it gets is going to keep going
i don't think so because it's just
inconceivable to me that the politicians
can maintain sort of the present level
of non-responsiveness of intellectual
bankruptcy of not being willing
to uh to raise issues
because they can't afford to because of
their contributors i think somebody's
going to move around that somebody's
going to stand up and somebody's going
to raise those issues and i think when
somebody does if he can measure up
say he or she but it's much more likely
to be a male politician
then i think you'll see turnout start to
rise again if it doesn't and there's
certainly a chance maybe they're two out
of two or three out of ten that it won't
happen
if that turnout doesn't start to rise
then you have to say the united states
is in some trouble and i have a short
time left are you getting tired of all
this
i sometimes have the feeling and i've
said this to people that
i have the horrible feeling it
it's like going into a movie and waiting
and this is where i came in
that a whole new politics maybe is about
to start maybe not
maybe it'll prove something maybe it'll
yield something and maybe it won't
uh maybe this time the politicians will
live up to expectations
but if they really do it'll be a first
uh normally what you get out of american
politics is these
short bursts of real creativity and and
coalition change and then it sort of
settles into a norm i think we've had a
lower norm than usual i hope there's a
real change coming
the name of the book is politics of rich
and poor wealth and the american
electorate in the reagan aftermath
our guest for the last hour has been
kevin phillips thank you mr phillips
thank you
[Music]
next week on book notes we'll discuss
the life of british prime minister
margaret thatcher our guest will be
chris ogden the chief diplomatic
correspondent from time magazine who
profiles mrs thatcher in his new book
entitled maggie an intimate portrait of
a woman in power
join us at 8 p.m eastern time next
sunday for a look at the life of
margaret thatcher followed by the
british house of commons question time
here on c-span
up next question time from the british
house of commons
[Music]
an american profile on c-span
take a front row seat for in-depth
conversation with the nation's leaders